today like current day would you say
that that covant IG is the number one
source of dolphins in captivity like is
that where most people are purchasing
their dolphins for aquariums or for
parks year after year after year I would
say yes but also I'm aware of a huge
export that's happening that most people
have no clue out of Cuba Cuba supplies a
lot of dolphins really yeah and we're
looking into that right now but we've
gotten you know if it's hard it's a
communist country so to get any
government data is almost impossible but
from what I'm hearing from people there
it's and there it could be close to
Taichi as far as the export that's in
Taiji I could look it up but I think
it's somewhere around one hundred and
something a year or a hundred a year
that maybe get exported I don't know if
Cuba's like that year after year or this
like sometimes I'll have a spike and
there won't be any exports but you know
throughout the Caribbean you have like
in Mexico I don't know if you've ever
been to Mexico but like there Tulum
every 1/2 mile there's a place to swim
with the dolphins for like 30 miles
there just one after the end of their
after another after another yeah a lot
of those are I think are coming from
Cuba and they're all you know all over
the Caribbean anywhere a cruise ship
stop you'll find all finns in captivity
and so i'm thinking a lot of those in
the caribbean are coming from Cuba the
Cuban doesn't do the slaughtering like
Taiji oh no but they have a National
Aquarium where they have dolphins and
they are always considered kind of like
Castro's pet dolphins and actually if I
remember correctly Che Guevara's nice
his niece is her sister it's his niece
is that like the national vet at the
aquarium why it's they're probably
involved in the export you know I'm sure
the higher up since you've already you
know making money off of that I have you
guys have any plans to go down there to
check that out at all yeah I live in
Miami so I don't have people I know
Cuban and I have friends that go back
and forth all the time so I've had
people looking
[Laughter]